das virus breite sich in mexiko rasend
schnell aus oft unerkannt unkontrolliert
etwa 900.000 menschen haben sich hier
schon mit 19 fixiert offiziell die
dunkelziffer noch viel größer getestet
wird vergleichsweise wenig ich bin in
der stadt merida im bundesstaat yucatan
ich will die menschen treffen die hier
am heftigsten unter der korona krise
leiden die indigenen maja deswegen
treffe ich heute und verbringe 36
stunden mit ihr oder hilft den
schwächsten durch die krise auf eigene
faust
ich frage mich warum sind vor allem die
indigenen so hart getroffen
meine reise in die welt der maya dörfer
beginnt ausgerechnet in einer bewachten
oberschicht gegend hier wohnt oder und
das überrascht mich
wie geht's gut in der die schöne für das
schön hast du es hier ja hier wohne ich
mit meiner familie hier ist mein
wohnzimmer meine küche wir werden am
abend noch mal vorbeischauen dann will
oder mir mehr über ihr eigenes leben
erzählen wir machen uns auf den weg
es ist sonntagmorgen die stadt ist
extrem ruhig ich war schon öfter als
reporterinnen dieser gegend und habe
mehr wieder viel quirliger in erinnerung
doch heute ist es wie ausgestorben legt
das von corona wie ist denn die
situation in mexiko in sachen corona ich
bin mir sicher dass nicht genug getestet
wird es gibt bestimmt mehr fälle als man
in den nachrichten hört das ist ja in
vielen ländern so hier ist es aber
ziemlich offensichtlich es geht viel
arbeitslosigkeit vor allem die
restaurant branche ist hart getroffen
alles ist geschlossen schon seit monaten
nutzt oder tiere sonntage nur noch dazu
lebensmittelspenden zu verteilen
kannst du mir erklären was wir heute
machen wir fahren in einige gemeinden
denen es nicht gut geht um sie so gut
wie möglich durch die zeit zu begleiten
ihnen etwas licht und frieden zu bringen
wir bringen ihnen lebensmittel spenden
jetzt fahren wir zu einem großmarkt im
zentrum wo unsere pakete gepackt werden
ein großer supermarkt stellt extra zwei
mitarbeiter dazu ab beim pakete packen
zu helfen
ein paket enthält grundnahrungsmittel
wie bohnen reis zucker öl kaffee aber
auch seife und
das ist für die kinder oder wie viel
kostet euch so ein paket im moment
kosten sie 160 ps aus so sind sie gut
ausgestattet und auch gut zu
transportieren
das ist nämlich auch so ein thema dax
wieder bedeutet so viel wie danke für
das leben das ist das motto für dieses
projekt und der name ihrer instagram
seite über die sie die geld spenden
sammelt davon bezahlt sie dann hier die
lebensmittel 150 pakete fertig zur
ausfuhr am steuer sitzt ja ein
unternehmer aus medida der sich schon
länger sozial engagiert und jetzt rudert
einmal die woche unterstützt die korona
pandemie hat mexiko hart getroffen
auch wirtschaftlich eine gruppe die ist
ziemlich mitgenommen hat sind die
haushaltshilfen hier in mexiko haben
hausmädchen keinen schutz
kein vertrag meistens keine
sozialversicherung niemand dazu sie
verantwortlich die meisten indigenen
maja frauen sind auf diese arbeit als
haushaltshilfe aber angewiesen denn für
diesen job braucht man keinen
schulabschluss
wir fahren zu ihnen und erreichen george
e ein abgelegenes dorf halo eine frau
pro haushalt wir treffen uns gleich an
der kirche der anfragen ist riesig
frauen jeden alters sind gekommen
es herrscht masken pflicht offiziell
gibt es hier zwar keine coop 19 fälle
es gibt aber auch keinen arzt oder
keinerlei tests um die infektion
überhaupt festzustellen
wir haben die sachen für 150 familien
dabei und ich hoffe dass das ausreichend
ich lange ist wirklich ziemlich lang
es sind ganz da vorne an da steht der
bus bis dahin
das ganze dorf ist pro haushalt gibt es
ein paket was corona angeht bin ich
vorsichtig ich selbst bin negativ auf
cobit getestet aber so ganz sicher sind
die ergebnisse ja nie was wenn ich doch
jemanden anstecken
es gibt hier kaum gesundheitliche
versorgung das ist dieser laute nicht
ich so gut kenne
sagen sie es bitte nochmal das in lokal
ist ein typischer laut in der meier
sprache personalausweis lesen fällt mir
leichter warum kommen sie hierher was
ist der grund dafür
ich lebe alleine
ich habe gearbeitet aber wegen der
pandemie hat mich meine chefin entlassen
elf jahre habe ich bei ihr gearbeitet
und sie hat mir nichts mit gegeben
vorher habe ich am tag 250 ps verdient
ich habe gewaschen gebügelt gekocht das
haus in ordnung gehalten sie bedient
immerzu essenszeit frühstück mittags
abends essen dreimal am tag
wir werden liberata gleich noch zu hause
besuchen wenn alle anderen versorgt sind
und macht derweil fotos von fast jeder
paket übergabe die veröffentlicht sie
auf social media das kurbelt weitere
spenden an
tja was fast der einzige mann weit und
breit mich beschäftigt die frage warum
nur frauen die spenden empfangen was ist
mit den männern
warum genau geben sie die pakete nur und
frauen ab naja also ehrlich gesagt
in ganz mexiko aber vor allem hier im
südosten
hier wird viel alkohol getrunken
die männer trinken vor allem am
wochenende wenn sie frei haben und ihr
geld bekommen hat
deshalb benutzen sie das geld um alkohol
zu kaufen und sie könnten die
lebensmittelspenden dazu benutzen um sie
gegen alkohol einzutauschen
[Musik]
es sind die frauen die hier die soziale
verantwortung in der familie übernehmen
das ist in entwicklungs und
schwellenländern meistens so mexiko ist
geprägt von einer sehr großen sozialen
ungleichheit und die allermeisten
indigenen befinden sich auf der seite
der armut meistens ohne chance auf
aufstieg sie werden seit der eroberung
durch die spanier im 16 jahrhundert
systematisch klein gehalten
schlechte bildung dadurch kaum
aufstiegschancen und wenig zugriff auf
landbesitz dabei ist mexikos indigene
kultur eine der größten und
vielfältigsten auf der ganzen welt hier
in yucatan leben bis heute viele meyer
übrigens gibt es in mexiko und umgebung
bis heute etwa sechs millionen menschen
die sich als mayer identifizieren die
allermeisten von ihnen leben ein
ärmliches einfaches leben
wir sind bei liberata zuhause der frau
die ich eben in der vergabe schlange
kennengelernt hatte
[Musik]
ich mag das alles
ich bin nicht so dass ich sage das will
ich aber nicht und das nicht ich esse
alles hier kommt nichts weg
ich bin sehr glücklich damit
das reicht mir erst mal so für 15 tage
oder mehr
ja ich bin allein ich esse von den
wohnen hier in drei tagen ein halbes
kilo
danke an die leute die herkommen uns zu
unterstützen
das ist sehr wichtig für sie oder ich
hab dir ja schon gesagt ich lebe alleine
das hier hilft mir sehr viel
wie gut dass die leute heute hergekommen
sind ich wusste dass gar nicht es ist
eine überraschung
die berater zeigt mir ihr wohnzimmer ihr
allerheiligstes hier schläft und betet
sie wie fast alle mal epli berater ein
mix aus indigenen bräuchen und
katholischem glauben der den
ureinwohnern durch die spanische
eroberung gewaltsam aufgezogen wurde
im namen des vaters des sohnes und des
heiligen geistes gottmann jesus du wirst
auf mich aufpassen
ich bin alleine aber ich bin die immer
dankbar
plötzlich fängt liberata beim gebet an
zu weinen
ich bin so alleine wirklich und wie ich
eben schon erzählt habe das was mir
gegeben wird dass es sich auch aber geld
ich habe kein geld ich versuche sie zu
beruhigen
manchmal da fühle ich mich einfach
alleine
ich bin alleine ich habe niemanden meine
schwestern
wer weiß wo die sind die wohnen in
merida oder so
ihre kinder auch niemand kommt her ich
begreife dass liberata sich komplett im
stich gelassen führt nicht nur von ihrer
familie sondern auch von den
mexikanischen gesellschaft mit ihrem job
als haushälterin hat sie durch die
pandemie auch das letzte bisschen
soziale versorgung verloren
das grundstück und ihr häuschen hat sie
geerbt sie sind ihr ganzer stolz
und der einzige halt meine ehemalige
chefin will nicht dass ich komme und
gehe
sie meinte sie will nicht dass ich krank
werde wenn du kommst und geest kommst du
gehst dann macht mir das angst dass du
dir die krankheit ein fängst und sie mir
ins haus schleppte sie meinte sie will
ein hausmädchen dass bei ihr einzieht
da bleibt aber das will ich nicht die 63
jährige hat im moment 0 1 kommen
sie hat die hoffnung aufgegeben neue
arbeit zu finden ihre kleidung nicht sie
sich selbst doch jetzt ist auch noch
ihre nähmaschine kaputt gegangen
wenigstens zeiten meine schuhe schon
seit einem jahr
gott sei dank hatten meine schuhe so
lange durch den es noch nichts passiert
es ist zeit sich zu verabschieden ich
würde dich gerne umarmen und einen kuss
geben aber das können wir im moment
nicht für liberata war ihr job in der
stadt das pendeln dorthin die brücke zum
rest der gesellschaft
diese verbindung ist durch die pandemie
gekappt
natürlich wäre es für sie riskant mit
der vierten verkehrsmitteln also mein
bus
zu reisen zur arbeit und zurück zu
fahren
es kann sich dabei an zu stärken
aber andererseits
es ist ja auch keine lösung jetzt ist
sie zu hause ganz alleine
keine keine von
doch weiß gar nicht mehr wie sie
durchkommen
[Musik]
mit meinem mietwagen fahre ich ohne
ansteckungsgefahr zurück in die stadt
und kommen nach einer dreiviertel stunde
wieder in der anderen welt an ballett zu
hause
nach zwölf stunden pakete packen
verteilen und fotografieren will sie
jetzt noch die fotos bearbeiten und
online stellen um neue geld spenden zu
sammeln oder vater ist
transportunternehmer er konnte ihr ein
grafik design studium ermöglichen viele
reisen
ich war in costa rica haben einen
austausch nach chile gemacht denn nach
mexiko-city gegangen
ziemlich abwechslungsreich ich war
überall unterwegs nur nicht in merida
bot steht die ganze welt offen
und trotzdem hat sie sich aus freien
stücken dazu entschieden denen zu helfen
die in ihre heimat auf der schattenseite
leben hast du denn das gefühl dass du
auch eine verantwortung das zu etwas zu
machen zu helfen
ja absolut
die verantwortung kommt dann wenn man
diese andere welt kennen lernt menschen
die so etwas noch nicht gesehen und
erfahren haben die wissen nicht dass es
so eine bedürftigkeit gibt oder wie
einfach es ist wie es geht zu helfen
aber wenn du weißt wie du dich verlassen
kannst wie du spenden sammelst wem du
helfen kannst dann hast du diese soziale
verantwortung dann kannst du die augen
nicht mehr verschließen und sagen ich
will das nicht sehen dass da draußen
hilfe benötigt wird
über ihr netzwerk hat in den vergangenen
monaten bereits 4000 pakete kaufen und
verteilen können und die spenden werden
nicht weniger im gegenteil
dann zeigt sie mir bilder aus der
schwersten zeit in diesem jahr im juni
nach einem schweren tropensturm wurde
die region um merida von wassermassen
überschwemmt wie immer bei solchen
fluten sind es hier wieder die
abgelegenen dörfer der maya die am
schwersten getroffen sind deshalb
wirklich hart für alle eine wirklich
harte erfahrung zum beispiel mein freund
der mit mir dort war der konnte das gar
nicht verarbeiten
er war todtraurig und meinte warum gibt
es keine gerechtigkeit warum bin ich
hier in diesem haus und die andere nicht
ich glaube dass man niemals allen helfen
kann aber du kannst dein bestes geben
ist zu versuchen unser erster
gemeinsamer tag ist vorbei und es
pragmatismus beeindruckt mich tief sie
könnte sich auch den kopf darüber
zermartert wie ungerecht das alles ist
aber stattdessen
packte die sache halt einfach an das
finde ich schon finde ich schon recht
bald
sie macht das nicht immer ehrenamtlich
auch ihr richtiger job ist
etwas ähnliches wie sehen die geben
familien hilft und das wird sie uns
morgen zeigen
der zweite tag oder fährt mit mir in ein
anderes meyer dorf noch weiter draußen
heute besuchen wir leute die er mit
kunsthandwerk arbeiten die betroffen
sind weil der tourismus eingebrochen ist
der touristenmagnet im dschungel von
yucatan ist chichen itza die bekannteste
aller maya pyramiden und eines der
sieben weltwunder der moderne
normalerweise kommen 14 millionen
touristen im jahr her
jetzt legt der tourismus brach und die
mauer die von ihm leben bleiben ohne
einkommen santa rosa ein altes
bauerndorf die maya frauen hier arbeiten
trotzdem weiter schlechten körper mit
fasern die sie aus agave pflanzen
herstellen sie wollen ihre produkte nun
online vertreiben oder will ihnen dabei
helfen in ihrem hauptjob arbeitet sie
für eine stiftung
ich erfahre sieben todesfälle hat es in
santa rosa gegeben
man munkelt es könne corona gewesen sein
getestet wird auch hier nicht
wir besuchen maria sie lebt
traditionelle hängematten auch das
hängematten geschäft liegt im moment
ziemlich brach spaßeshalber lässt sie
mich auch mal ran ich habe ziemlich
angst ihr die aufwändige matte mit einer
falschen masche zu ruinieren
wie lange brauchen sie für so eine
hängematte
das dauert ziemlich und ist ganz schön
anstrengend so drei wochen dass es viel
arbeit
etwa 70 euro für drei wochen arbeit aber
ohne touristen keine käufer für ihre
waren und somit keine einnahmen
die soziale ungleichheit in mexiko
beschäftigt mich sehr hat maria das
gefühl dass die schere zwischen arm und
reich durch die korona pandemie noch
größer wird
darüber habe ich noch gar nicht so
nachgedacht im moment betrifft die
pandemie uns ja alle die reichen und die
armen natürlich trifft es die armen
schlimmer weil sie keinen kapital haben
die anderen haben mehr geld in der bank
oder was zurückgelegt aber die armen
leben von tag zu tag
man arbeitet um zu essen und um die
familie zu versorgen
ich glaube dass es einen großen
unterschied macht ob man ein geld
polster für schlechte zeiten hat oder
nicht
in mexiko ist aktuell jeder auf sich
alleine gestellt der staat hilft weder
privatpersonen noch unternehmen
finanziell überrascht ist davon niemand
hier
sie haben es nicht anders erwartet die
regierung hat uns in der vergangenheit
schon so oft bestohlen
sie haben uns schon so oft so tief
verletzt das zerstört das vertrauen der
menschen gegenüber denen die an der
macht sind
es ist vor allem die korruption die alle
ebenen der mexikanischen gesellschaft
fest im griff und den glauben an den
guten willen der politiker zerstört hat
was glaubst du wie wird sich mexiko
verändern nach dieser krise nach dieser
pandemie
es kommt drauf an wie man es sieht
klar wird es negative seiten geben es
wird eine wirtschaftskrise und noch
andere probleme geben aber ich glaube
auch dass die gesellschaft sehr
zusammengerückt ist um zu helfen
es gibt viel solidarität empathie
zusammenarbeit für ein gemeinsames ziel
krisen führen dazu dass die leute
zusammenhalten
es wird viele negative sachen geben aber
die positiven dinge die sind auch sehr
sehr gewichtig du bist optimistisch nach
36 stunden bin ich weniger optimistisch
vielmehr mache ich mir sorgen dass sie
in die den menschen in mexiko durch die
krise noch mehr in die armut gedrängt
und dadurch abgehängt werden als sie es
vorher schon waren
warum
generell kommt besonders hart getroffen
ist
jetzt sagen kann ist
einfach keine
es gibt keine ersparnisse
eine schwere zeit
einfach nur
vorbei geht
die situation
vor